what was it what you [ __ ] actually I
don't was worth the $30 are you to mount
the podcast you're talking the podcaster
yeah which one I'm talking about the
food you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
okay
hot breath verse this is it welcome back
to the hot breath podcast I'm whispering
because we're in a diner right now about
to do this interview I just want to
welcome you let you know I am your host
comedian Joel Byers
this is hot breath your weekly guide to
comedy mastery today's guest is an OG in
this game started comedy back in 1984
two years into the game had a quick
little layover in rehab where they told
him to not do comedy for another year
yet the day after he gets out he is back
on stage doing prestigious shows like
the one he did where he got paid with
the television instead of money he got
paid with a TV but dr. TV oh you stole
the TV I took it from him oh I thought
he was like I have a TV for well I say
give me your TV and he listened and
since then he's actually been on
television more than a hundred times he
was the first white comic on HBO's def
Comedy Jam a finalist on Last Comic
Standing
of course tough crowd with Colin Quinn
you know him from Opie and Anthony you
may not have known he's also written on
several roasts he's also been a writer
on the Academy Awards yes twice whoa
wrote for Chris Rock right twice yeah
wrote for Chris Rock twice he was also
he also came up producing shows and
headlining shows where Chris Rock was
actually his opener at one time along
with people like Ray Romano this is my
fiancee right here's his fiancee
bringing you challah bread is that yes
that's how she knew I was a Jew that's
what I was gonna I didn't want to say it
I look to Gentile I'm too Goya to make
that joke so all that being said we're
about to learn from a master so buckle
up wait wait you didn't mention the
movie women aren't funny that we made
yes with your wife Bonnie McFarlane
who's your top he made it was a great
comic and you bet you produced it right
we guys made it all yourself yes we
women aren't funny he also has a podcast
with his wife
called my wife hates me yes so anything
else on it and the best roast you'll
ever see at Vostro stock boss rose calm
I saw the trailer that's all I saw it's
the best roast its murderers row Colin
Quinn Jim Norton Bobby Kelly Florentine
BJ duro Shibani
Judy gold murderers row yeah it's a it's
a different it's a different game up
there in New York you guys you guys
don't don't use gloves up there it's all
bare-knuckle up there we're real yeah
we're not thin-skinned you know like
these young comics you say something
negative they go well what's that about
it's about a joke you [ __ ] idiot all
right you're a comic all right so you
know I mean I'm from a crew of honest
ball-busters Kevin Hart
Patrice me Norman Keith Billy you know I
mean Kevin Hart and Billy are doing a
little better now just much better than
much better than the Patrice but where
some say Patrice got out just in the
nick of time before he was gonna have to
start working like that which would have
been the best comic out now well the
best to me too probably the best comic
in my opinion this is Stan hope he's
Bobby he's Devlin now it's it's weird
Stanhope Colin Quinn Billy Louie and me
and you of course I was gonna put you at
the top of that list no I'm not at the
top but she I could do things that
people just can't do and there's
business I'm just so versatile you know
when it comes to I could do any crowd
Doug Stanhope is a genius he can't do
any crowd
well maybe you can now I can't do kids
what's the what's kind of the secret
behind being able to do every crowd
living life and having experience in
life and just knowing people just being
real because you meet you come from like
comics that are real is that something
younger comics lack is just that real a
lot of them are good writers uh-huh but
you're doing comedy from the head
nothing from the heart but maybe you
know takes time to find your voice you
know you got these young guys they're
great writers or young girls but when
they leave or they're done how much do
you really know of them not saying you
have to know a comic that's just my
style I like and I'm pretty honest
onstage about my life and different
things and how I view things but it's
all great different types of comedy I
mean they're all great you know it's
somebody like Brian Regan
he's as funny as anybody who's ever been
alive everybody you know and then you go
to the other spectrum you give someone
like I stand hope like I said or loi you
know justice you know and you know you
get Maria Bamford who's as funny as
anybody who's ever been alive you know
and then you get you know just the
opposite but that I mean category
because she's so funny and and so
different so out of her mind thank you
she's you know but do you bring me water
I did bring you know [ __ ] yourself it's
high official hot breath water though
it's got our logo on it ours you do this
with other people no this is all this is
one-man band and why do you say ours
because we're the hot breath averse the
listeners and I it's our collective can
have you been doing this fly-by-night
podcast almost four years no really yeah
for you we're almost to 200 episodes Wow
I'm gonna put this on cuz I don't want
to get sauce on my shirt of I mean yeah
it can't get any uglier the sauce would
probably help it actually but it sure it
is so [ __ ] cool
what but then again look at you your
plain white guy right you're very white
I am you're very waspy are your parents
will get where they slave-owners your
grandparents I'm from the trailer
actually I look purebred but I'm inbred
did oh really you don't come from a long
line of bankers well this is spicy no
I'm like white trash but like
non-recyclable white trash this is 30
something dollars this is not a $30
something I I mean it's free for monster
I mean would shrink and they say it's
Lobster it's probably some kind of
[ __ ] what do you call it flew at me
probably crayfish but how long did it
take you to find your voice because what
it what I've as you're chewing and I'm
now I've heard you say you started out
experimenting you went like through a
Steven Wright phase where you're very
deadpan then you went through a Robin
Williams phase we were very animated so
like through that process how long did
it take you to hone in and become rich
boss not rich he's definitely not rich
but rich boss well you don't know how
rich I am I'm doing rich with regrets I
don't know I guess as I progressed and
got more sober and
got older and experienced more I started
you know I'm still working on finding
out you know trying to be I always try
to get better and improve you know and I
want to be as honest as I can but I also
look I do cry if I do crowd work I don't
do it as much as I used to
that's not fun it's just being it's not
finding your voice it's just doing crowd
work which is this hard as any some
comic single I see it's hard as
everything yeah who do good crowd work
big J is great a crowd work oh my gosh
the master no he's not the master I'm
the [ __ ] master you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love out for little jabs and now we
did that on purpose you wait and then
just like hit like hey makers the master
he's great at it no he's really good
great at it I interviewed I Ian bagg on
here about it - he's great yeah and his
system was like you just have a
conversation with the people yeah
they're not trying to set up a joke no
you're just you're having a conversation
something will come out of it exactly
yeah so good crowd work I will take
everything in full circle and make it
into a story almost mm-hmm you know big
J Ian Todd Barry's good mm-hmm
yeah this whole comic Jimmy Brogan was
good from LA and you know I was the best
and you do the bet still the best still
hey but it's fun to hear and I think
that's good perspective for comics is
that over 30 years into this game you're
still like I'm still trying to get
better I'm still constantly trying to
learn you gotta give us what else you
stagnate who the [ __ ] wants to do that
then you you're working in a cubicle
mm-hmm yeah you know that's one thing
club owners agents managers cannot take
from you is your creativity
so and you've done it all released five
albums and you've done it all yourself
yeah you've you've really kind of create
your own success in many ways right yeah
you know I'd you know all my own I'm
gonna make it a six album now I think
but yeah I do all myself my my wife and
I my wife very [ __ ] creative she's
one of the best writers in the business
one of the best comics in the business
hands down just had a big article in New
York Times writes directs I mean she's
way more versatile than me a hundred
times on and we create a lot of our own
projects our own shows we do shows in
Moontower Montreal shows that we created
and and no one's no one's throwing
anything at you in this business once in
a blue moon someone will get something
here and their friend will help them or
a younger guy or a very talented actor
comic so you got a real you got a lot of
the competition and you got to create
your own stuff mmm-hmm so for for
younger comics I think it's important
you talk about all the people you're
surrounded by up in New York and you
surround yourself with talented best
don't get don't get caught up in an open
mic around other people that are just
there to just like hang out but surround
yourself with comics that really want to
get better and then are better than you
right yeah okay cuz you even married you
know you even married like a super
talented person to keep you yes don't
tell me if my [ __ ] is [ __ ] mmm-hmm
no you can't do that one wake up to
what's going on in the world now you
know you know I mean it's good to do as
many open it's good to get on I go I'm
gonna look like the other night get on
stage whenever you can if you're new
comic get on you know don't you're not
too good for that place you're not too
good for any place
get on that's how you're gonna get good
hang out with good comics hang out with
good cop no it's just like in recovery
hang out with the winners you're hanging
out with somebody that's you know as
reservations or this these meetings
soccer this sucks
they're good yeah you're not gonna get
you're not gonna learn you're gonna go
backwards mm-hmm anything in life it
athletes try to play with better
athletes so they become when I play golf
I whenever I'm playing with better
golfers I always step up my game you
always step up your game when you're
with better people so what I'm saying is
step up your game with this [ __ ]
podcast we've got you on here now it's
all the way up or it's the beginning of
the end nobody else will come on because
I heard you were on your please I had a
clout and [ __ ] email me mark Normand
and Joel s yo [ __ ] deal they don't say
no to anything
Seinfeld just shot it out mark Normand
did you hear that yeah he's the next
comic to watch yeah cuz he didn't have a
name to throw out but I just said I said
those two names because in researching
you the only picture I could find was a
view and Martin element there's a
million pictures of me and Patrice and
me has it been on here you killed them
me and Nour yeah he's bobbing here yet
all of all of them will be on here
except Patrice but those are the ones
that were on here and it seemed to be
most immediately connected to you anyway
so that's why I said their names but
however it worked well you're here you
get Florentine I haven't yet I've never
met him or seen him here why do you get
Bobby Kelly when he works Marshalls room
he's here in August yeah I'm gonna reach
out to him and you're gonna go Voss did
it
I will actually well you guys go away by
mean you guys yes we're doing a tour
together
exactly so Ken can I just say whatever
you want about his drawer a lot towards
me Bobby Kelly jim Florentine and Ron
Bennington creeps we kids go to creeps
with kids calm mmm
we have already booked 16 theaters and
but it's funny you meant when you talk
about younger comics I've heard you say
that you think a lot of them are just
like arrogant now well you don't really
I don't know if your average I don't
know if it's arrogant well yet what it
is is the a lot of them have don't know
any history about comedy they do know
research you know and there's now you
look it's a new day and age obviously
you to Instagram this and that but
there's comics that open up listen my
crew not my crew Collin tough crowd us
guys on tough crowd made it easier for
certain comics to be as edgy as they are
we were edgy on TV edgy so comics you
know young kids used to watch that and
they you know you did look up to certain
people Patrice or calling or Nick Norton
some me so and I started coming I looked
up to comics I used to love watching the
older comics because they were [ __ ]
great it was a different you know guys
like Bob Newhart or Steve Landis Berg
you know this guy said new comics now
we'll have no idea who the [ __ ] they are
you know and it's important also watch
and learn from comics like you know when
you're in town like people like there
should be comics here that are studies
crazy dead it's not packed with new
comics whenever I work or any if Bobby's
here yeah or any headliner and there's
no new comics watching it's crazy I used
to go watch comics of course
oh my god if I wasn't on stage I was in
a club watching yeah headliner how are
you gonna learn Lou now let's say that's
hafsat luenell said that's the biggest
problem with young comics this
generation is they don't study they
don't watch you know I cut you off where
were you going with that up sighs I
don't I don't remember no I used to
watch I'm just saying you know look new
comics someone will sit in the back and
go or judge a headline
it's so [ __ ] funny you know
Deb you know just no clue you learn it's
just like when you go to a 12-step
meeting you listen to somebody that has
15 20 years sober you listen to them
because you know they're doing something
right yeah and you thirty years in the
game what are what are thirty five
thirty thirty five I didn't want to age
you I don't care I'm all of the +62 I
just turned 62 and I'm still [ __ ]
relevant I mean think about it
yeah I'm not bragging I'm just saying I
mean my wife helps a lot to being witty
she's younger and and we're married a
headlining married couple mm-hmm so that
helps keep me relevant to some but how
have you dealt with like the highs and
lows of such a long career I'm sure like
the peaks and valleys you know I eat a
posh and seafood during the lows which
helps get me through especially when
it's not on your tab if you get $30
pasta cuz it's not on your tab it is how
my tab because the people that are
eating here are here because they're
coming to see me uh-huh so all the years
of traveling and doing whatever pays for
this [ __ ] dinner see what I'm saying
yeah you've earned it I've earned it
yeah and it's a diner what other tips as
we can start landing this plane here so
you can enjoy this like I'm enjoying
this you aren't just I'm an [ __ ] and
I'm I'm so I sounds so self-righteous
and so [ __ ] you know I'm what he
called
what's the word I can't even think I
can't think of it it'll come to me
self-righteous you know and I'm poppin
pontificating you know [ __ ] in here I'm
not even trying to be funny because you
know I'm not a [ __ ] what watch this
guy staring at us a dancing monkey you
know just talking comedy look that's
what people want to hear yeah we have a
live podcast now that's what happens
when you record in a diner it's good
food what's maybe from all the times at
the table and all the times you like at
the cellar and all the times you guys
would then go and play basketball to
like you know well that's when you do
this what podcast should you listen to
to get this information as soon as you
agreed I went headfirst into rich vos
world and just absorbed everything I'd
do that with every interview so good
when people listen to this I want them
to know if they listened to hot breath
they're gonna get everything from this
person they're gonna learn everything
they need to know about them it's like
looking at so many comics have a podcast
so how can I do one that's going to
stand out from all the others kill
yourself on it that can be our 300th
episode they're still alive of course
you are in your 60s but if you're still
alive of the three hundreds and do it
together but you go first you really
have gotten me thinking in like the
comedy brain more of like just always
just like just busting balls and always
thinking more in terms of just comedy
and not taking things so seriously cuz
like you you said most comics are they
get the writing but not the heart
I was just conversation last night where
I literally like I was talking another
comic and it was the writing but he's
like it's effective laughter but they're
like it's not memorable laughter no you
don't walk out knowing that person or
yeah you not saying you have to know
everybody because you don't but
I don't know it's listen there's certain
there's stirs and this is not mine
there's Keith this is Keith Robinson's
theory and that's a great theory guy
there's continuity I went to school and
the kids that sat in the front of the
bus we're not as funny as the kids on
the back of the bus so there's fun of
the bus funny in comedy and there's back
of the bus funny the back of the bus
funny is [ __ ] funny
but the front of the bus can be funny
mm-hmm you see what I'm saying this is
Keith's theory not mine
Keith Robinson yeah that's a great
theory because you're funny the bus is
like there's comics that learn they're
like mathematicians and learn how to do
comedy hmm there's comics that are
[ __ ] comics there's just comics they
didn't learn they learn how to get
better than that but they didn't they
didn't read a book on comedy it's like
again I'll bring it back to them like in
rehab you go to rehab you have
counselors there you have counselors
that went to school and learned and
became a counselor with a degree or you
have counselors that are ex-drug addicts
that went through whatever to get a
degree but direct drug addicts the ex
drug addicts are the better counselors
because they they lived that same
[ __ ] life as you so there's there's
people that teach from the heart and
they feel the teeth from the head this
healing centers feel that performed
comedy from the heart and people that
form from the head not saying what's
better any others one's different just
different but myself I'll always go in
the back of the bus comic that's it for
me I've been doing it from the head for
nine years what advice do you have to
start bringing the heart into it well
talk about your life
talk about your passions look
raining good jokes being a Raider
there's so many great writers and you
know and and there's great comics look
at Jeselnik he's a great writer mm-hmm
that's not real it's not real but it's
great funny you know what I mean of
course he's doing an act he's doing a
character it's [ __ ] great it's funny
but it's not Jeselnik that's what I yeah
I have the writing I want to bring I
want people to come afterwards to be
like that reminds me of this all right
I was I was thinking that you know I
want to hear those notes you know
whatever's going on in your life or huh
I don't know all your what you maybe
what you feel what's going on in
politics you're going on around the
world or this is like what you feel go
there instead of what you can for your
opinion on the opinion okay yeah I think
it was crazy that some idiot that works
behind a counter in Starbucks we tell
this business-wise would tell six cops
to leave because someone's uncomfortable
well one person is uncomfortable and
there's six people there you tell if
that one person that's comfortable to go
we may be used to leave that's its
business you got six people buying your
product or one you know besides all the
political correctness and all the
craziness behind it you know it's just
how and and there's stuff in the news
every [ __ ] day we got a [ __ ]
president that's arguing with a soccer
player on [ __ ] Twitter but for people
to get to know you I guess it's first
making your own life funny yeah but then
you can you can give your opinion on
things to just there's no right or wrong
okay
there's just what what you like or what
you want to do you know I would
I personally and well at some point we
just love to go up and tell stories that
happened in my life I've already done
enough Tommy you know I mean just funny
stories you know like a Colin Colin or I
think Theo Theo von tells stories you
know I heard a real funny one or couple
on radio and I would like to move in
that direction you know and you know
that's cool to hear you 35 years in
you're like I would like to try this now
and stay I'm moving that direct like I'm
funny but I can always be funnier no but
real stories like I tried to tell when
tonight about when I had anxiety and
went into the hospital but I didn't have
a punch I just brought it out just to
get it out and son you know I'll get it
working so I make it funny well tell him
you you committed yourself from so much
anxiety I did that's the story you told
yeah when I was here way I did I didn't
have a good punch I didn't have a punch
line I was just telling what it was like
back in the day when you've had anxiety
mmm-hmm so you know what was it was
[ __ ] actually I don't know worth the
$30 or you to mount the podcast you're
taught the podcast yeah I'm talking
about the food you [ __ ] [ __ ] so
before we get out of here how that that
was mark Norman it was he going great
yeah he's done this twice mark mark does
love comedy oh my god he does like
comedy oh yeah for sure
and he puts in the work for a robot he
likes comedy in closing this I like him
do you like this I like his accent yeah
I do I like his pants
that's why Seinfeld shouted him out
because he's like committed to the craft
where they're both the same [ __ ]
people though when you guys are busting
balls at Comedy Cellar where's Seinfeld
during all this what is he in LA
shooting his
he all has the TV show going on he
wasn't even around New York at the time
because I could just imagine you guys
roasting him whenever he walks in that
would be easy did you guys never got to
do that man
do you like Seinfeld I when I first
started I thought he was so [ __ ]
funny I thought he I thought he was the
funniest person alive and I always
thought he was funny
you know yeah he's Seinfeld it's chicken
oh he's cyfle yeah he's [ __ ] funny
he'll be back in the day though you know
he also took a gigantic sabbatical to do
his TV show
you know yeah to break TV his you know
he got back into it and you know he's
good but to me I'm not saying he's I
don't know when I cuz I don't really pay
attention to him as much anymore
I watched him the other night he was
funny you know but back in the day too
he was [ __ ] funny you know he talked
about the guy that lost all the weight I
lost really yeah you look like a rail
you know he there was a bit Oh some guy
weight 1,500 pounds or whatever even he
lost 300 pounds
what's this president hey you look great
yeah you know you were just so [ __ ]
funny you know so many great comics back
then oh my god imagine are you still
love watching them watching them comics
study what any other advice cuz I don't
want to push this too close to your
saying yeah our closing advice for
comics yeah be funny be funny
all right well
then go to Voros calm and go [ __ ]
yourselves what is that is that you have
a realize I keep these all documented so
you have your marching orders hot breath
averse get funny get around funny people
study funny people like rich here thanks
for you know thank you for having me I'm
sorry I'm sorry that you had to ruin my
meal but thank you well I just used you
so I can start name-dropping Jim actual
famous comics thank you
[Music]
[Music]
my breath